では よろしくお願いします
では これからリラックスする
リラックスですか まあ私はちょっと発音がリラックスと言うんですからね
で まあそれを覚えておいてください
リラックスという言葉についてお話しさせていただきます
えーと まあリラックスしましょうということはよく聞かれているんですが
あれって一体何なのかと本当に定義できないんですね
なんかみんな知ってるようで全く知らない
で この瞑想なんかに教えている時でも
やっぱりずっと私は言いますけど
まあやるとリラックスしてやらなきゃうまくいかないんだよと
うーん なんかわからないんですよ
リラックスって一体何なのかと
これがわからないと リラックスしようと言ったっても
リラックスできるわけじゃないんですよ
本当にそれを真剣に考えた方がいいんですよ
皆様方 ご自分に聞いてみてください
リラックスというのはどんな状態でしょうか？と
落ち着いているという
普通の日本語では落ち着いているということですよ
緊張していない状態 ものすごく落ち着いている状態
一体あの状態って何なのかと
各ご自分の心に聞いてみてください
これがおそらくわからないと思いますよ
だからわからない状態を作り作れと言ってもね
これできないんですよ
怒ってくださいと言ったらすぐわかるでしょうに
経験あるんだからね それぐらいだったら別に簡単にできる
何かに欲を出すことやらね
興味を示すことやらね
そういう感じがわかるんだけど
このリラックスということがわからないんですよ
これすごい大変 残念なことでもあります
残念というよりは なんかもうまあ損しているんですよ
で あの 私もこのリラックス
リラックスということを
えっと まあ簡単に説明できるかなとかね
と緊張して考えたんですよ
これなんか簡単に説明できる方法ないかなと
それで私はリラックスなくなっちゃったんですけど
なかなかないんですよ
こういう風に言えば もうこれは分かりやすくて
みんなにできるんでしょうというふうなね
なかなかないんです で
まあ今度のテーマとしてはね
まあ一応まあ仕事でも何でも
まあリラックスしてうまくいけるようにという話なんですけど
まあ俗世間ではね まあ集中できて
リラックスできて うまく仕事を運べるとという話をしちゃうとね
なんかまあ欲の話になってしまうんですよ
お釈迦様は全部捨てて解脱しなさいと言ってるんだからね
あまりなんか仏教においては
まあこの関係ない話にもならないわけでもないんです
もう全部捨てなさいと言っている世界だから
またうまく仕事いける方法とか
そんなこと言っちゃったら逆の話になっちゃいますからね
しかし このある王家の人が出家して
あの すごいすごい真面目に修行したんですよ
ものすごい真面目に修行して
体も贅沢に慣れている体だから
この出家の厳しい生き方なんかっていうのは
もうもう何もできるわけじゃない
しかし 頑張ってるんですよ
贅沢も全部やめて もうほとんど徹夜
夜寝ないで修行する まあ夜はもう体疲れて眠くなっちゃいますから
もう歩く瞑想したりとかね
頑張るは頑張るは頑張るは
もうなかなか成果が出てこない
ものすごい真面目で頑張っていたんですけど
成果がない でお釈迦様がその王家の人がね
まあ一生懸命頑張ってるんだけど
なかなか成果もないことで
すごくあ これが大変やと
なんとか協力してあげなくちゃいけないんですかとですよと思って
その人を呼びました 呼んで
まああんたどうですか？ちゃんとしっかり修行頑張ってますかと言ったら
もう私は怠けないです
もう徹底的に頑張ってますよと言ったら
お釈迦様がそのことについてもう何も言わないで
いきなり突然 君出家する前にかなり演奏上手でしたねとかね
楽器を 弦楽器を まあヴィーナーですけどね
君 すごい家で出家する前に弦楽器上手でした
まあそれはそれでということで
まあそれはもう考えたくもない
もう全て捨てて出家してるんだからね
でもお釈迦様はどんどんこの俗世間の話を引っ張るんですよ
まあせっかくお釈迦様が聞くんだから
答えない 答えまあ 答えていないわけにも答えないでいるわけにもいきませんし
で 答えるんですね それでどうですかね
すごい立派に演奏するときは
まあどんな風にこの楽器をあんた調整するんでしょうかとか
それについて聞くんですね
で まず聞いたのは もうではきつく
このすごい音を出そうと思ってね
もうきつくこの弦を 締まっておけばどうですかと
でお釈迦様に私はあれやった
すごいギリギリに締めてしまう
硬く 何て言いますか え？締めておいた方がいいと私は思います
じゃあいいえ お釈迦様
それ違いますと これはプロだからね
この人は それは違いますよと
それで音が出ないんですよと
全然音楽的な音は出てきませんよ
まあ雑音が出るかもしれませんだけど
あ そうか ということは緩めちゃうでしょうねと
で 緩めればいいでしょうと言ったら
お釈迦様はそれに緩めても音は出ませんよと
緩めても音出ませんよと言ったところで
なんとなくその人はもう機嫌がいいんですよ
自分が慣れている専門分野について
お釈迦様もとんでもないことを言ってるんだから
もうちょっと考えれば
お釈迦様もそれ知ってるはずなんですけど
同じもう性格していたんだから
それでのお釈迦様 次にではすごい立派な音を出すために
にはどうすればいいでしょうかね？と
それはね もうあまりにも締めすぎず
緩めすぎず その曲に合わせるんだよと
弦を それはそう簡単にできるわけじゃないんだと
だからこの弦楽器の場合は
締めたままでは演奏できません
そのその呼吸やらノートやら変わるたびにいろいろ調整しなくちゃいけないんですよ
だからそれも結構仕事なんですよ
楽器の調整というものも
それでお釈迦様にはものすごく説明しますよ
この人は  こういう風に
この弦だったらこういう風なぐらいで
この弦だったらこれぐらいで
まあきちんと合わせなくちゃいけないんだと
1本1本の弦が自分勝手で綺麗な音を出しても
次の弦とはそれはまた合わせないと
ということで それだったら立派に見事に綺麗な音楽の演奏できますよと
そしたらお釈迦様は そうですかね
まあこの修行というものもね
そんなもんですよ じゃあ頑張ってくださいと
だから結局お釈迦様にやられたということになりましたけど
やっぱりお釈迦様は見事にその人にこのリラクゼーションの方法を教えたんですよ
これ簡単じゃないということもそちらであるんですよ
はい リラックスしましょうと
冗談じゃないんです できるわけないんですよ
よくよく聞こえますよ
はい ではみんなリラックスして
はい 呼吸を整えてとかね
そんな言ったって リラックスが何なのかとわかりませんだからね
まあ片足で立ってくださいとかね
左足前に出してください
そしたらそれできますけどね
はい 深呼吸しましょうと言ったらそれはできますけど
ではリラックスして呼吸始めましょうと言ったら
それがわからないんですよ
だからリラックスというのはそう簡単にわかるものではなく
かなりの大事な仕事なんですね
だから仏教に縁のない話ではないんですよ
ほんとリラクゼーションの方法とかどこにあるかというと
別に経典なんかにはあるわけないんですよ
私は苦労して喋らなくちゃいけないんです
で 苦労して喋らなくちゃいけないんだけど
では仏教に関係ない話かというと
全然関係ない話ではありません
今言ったエピソードは確実に経典にあるエピソードで
楽器を調整するように
心と体を調整して修行しなさいと
ですから皆様ご理解理解していただきたいのは
リラクゼーションというのは微妙な調整のことなんですよ
微妙な調整のこと 体と心の
それがそういい加減簡単にできるということには成り立ちません
だから楽器によっても調整の仕方が違うしね
打楽器の場合とかね 弦楽器の場合とかね
それからあれ 何て言いますか
吹くやつは管楽器の場合とかね
それぞれ調整のやり方は違うんでしょうしね
それで言いたいのは 自分の体を楽器で思う
どんな演奏をするかと
体と心を持って そのその演奏によって合わせるんですよ
例えば演奏っていうのは生きること
もう朝から晩までいろんなことをして生きていなくちゃいけない
そのいろんなことをしている
それはそのその仕事に一番いいコンディションに体と心を調整する
それがリラクゼーションの定義になるんですよ
コンディションの調整
まあ例えば具体的な何か人の例を出して考えちゃうと
もう 朝起きて家族と一緒にご飯食べるとで
その時は子供たちもいると
で その食卓で子供たちにも和やかな気持ちを作ってあげて
1日学校に行って元気で頑張れるようにとか
で 奥さんそれから仕事に出かけていくんだから
奥さんにもそれなりに機嫌よく家で家の仕事をできるような感じの自分の働きをしなくちゃいけないんですよ
黙って食って逃げるわけでは
ちゃんと自分の仕事をしたわけにはならないんですよ
だから その時の体と心の調整
どうせ子供はいろいろ朝は鈍いわ
起きはないわ いろんないろんなことがあったりして
それに朝早く起きた瞬間から怒鳴ったらいいんでしょうかと
なんでこんな調子？早くしなさいとかね
言ってはいいんでしょうかとかね
そこら辺で考えて それなりに朝だから誰も叱ってはいけませんと
怒鳴ってはいけませんと
これはいけません あれはいけませんと言ってはいけないんだと
すごく雰囲気を和やかな雰囲気を作って
そこでしっかりした人として自分の仕事をこなす
こなして 次に仕事に出ていくでしょうに
例えば 駅までメートルかメートルじゃなくて
キロぐらい歩かなくちゃいけない
そこで同じ調子で子供たちと朝ちょっとふざけていろいろ遊んでいた調子で外を出ていいかなと
また自分を変えないと
道路で毎日住んでいるところだったら
いろんな人が知ってる可能性もあるし
あるいは一緒に仕事 別でも一緒に通勤する人々もいるかもしれませんし
また ゴミ出している他の奥さんたちやらね
まあもう顔を合わせる可能性もあるし
その場合はどんなコンディションで駅まで歩くかっていうこと
どんな心構えで それまた別なんですよ
で それでまあ隣の奥さんにおはようございます
なんとか言って なんとかそうやって褒め言葉を言ったり
他の知ってる人が見たらそれなりに挨拶して
自分もしっかり歩いて
丁寧に歩いて駅まで行ったとします
それ電車に乗った時のあの道路で歩いた状態でできますかね？できないでしょうに
その時の人間関係はまたものすごく変わっちゃうんですよ
家から駅までの人間関係と
電車に乗ってから降りるまでと
それも人間関係ですよ
誰とも喋らなくたっても
その時どういうふうなコンディションでしょうかと
それで会社に行くわ 仕事をするわ
休むわ 帰るわ いろんなことをしているんですね
だからいつでも同じ態度ではできない
仕事終わって 飲み屋で酒飲んで
カラオケ歌ってふざけている
あんな調子で仕事もするんだったら
あんな調子で家にもいるんだったら
もう１年以内で離婚になるでしょうに
だからリラクゼーションというのは
あるこれというものではありません
その場で その場で見事に立派に成功して
良い結果を出すために
失敗しないために 自分の体と心のコンディションを合わせる
ですね だから説明しにくいものになっているんです
だからそれは一人一人の仕事になっているんです
例えば 私のリラクゼーションの方法を皆様に教えても役に立ちません
私の仕事も違うし 生き方も違うし
別な人間でしょうし 皆様のリラクゼーションの方法を私に教えてくれたっても全然使用できません
だから これだけは自分で発見しなくちゃいけないんです
だから ちょっと精神安定剤飲んだりとかね
そういうふうな危険なことでリラックスとかなんとか思ってもいけませんよ
例えば 緊張してなんかもうある場合はもう簡単に薬で抑えてもらうことはできますけど
あれがリラクゼーションではないんです
それ私は一回自分の先生に長老にやっちゃったんだから
目の手術がしなくちゃいけないし
で ずっと医者のところに行かない
もうなんか心配で とにかく私が行くまで国へ行くまで待っていて
それで国に至っても忙しくて
ほとんど 1週間  1ヶ月間しかないし
で やっぱり緊張するんですね
だから私がいるとまあなんとかなるでしょうということで
とにかくそれで行って
もう強引に医者を責めて
日にちを強引に決めてもらって
もうできません できません
たくさんありますからとか
とにかくなんとかもうこの間で入れてくださいと言ったら
入れてはくれたんですね
もしかすると手術できなくなるかもしれません
前の手術を遅くなっちゃうとダメですよとも言われたんですね
とにかくまあ そこら辺のできるだけ手を打って
医者と仲良くして手術してもらったんですよ
手術の前の日から まあ長老の調子が良くない
かなり緊張している 私は全然気にしないでふざけてるんだから
もう結局さらに緊張する
こいつはいい加減ではないかという感じもあるし
いい加減ではなくて 裏でやることは全部やってはいるんですけど
それは全然言う必要はないんだから
まあ言わないし それでこれが困ったもんやと思って
若い医者がいて アシスタントで仕事をする
その人のところに行ってね
本当は長老 年でね あまり物事わからないんだろう
だからすごく怖がっているんだよと
で これ困るんだから もうもうなんとかしてちょうだいと言ったら
ほんの少量のたった 1錠だけ
普通 2錠飲むものを飲みたいんですけど
だったらほんの少量のこれ
まあ飲ませましょうということで
で 朝それ飲んでもらったんで
本人は知らない 何飲んでいたかっていうのも
ただ普通の薬やと思っただけでね
そこで飲んでからは あの言葉も大げさな言葉もないし
緊張することもなくて,なんかすごく落ち着いてますよ
外から見ればかなり落ち着いているなという感じですけど
本人がやっぱりわかってるんですよ
なんかおかしいと で そこで手術も終わって
すぐ 30分ぐらいで帰ってきたんですけど
帰ってきてもうーんなんかおかしいね
何やと 何がおかしいんですかと
普通はいつでも喧嘩するんですけどね
やっぱりそれもできないし
なんかその気にもならないしね
なんか薬 あれ なんか薬のせいではないかなと思いますね
やっぱり気づくんですよ
それでも私は言わなかったんですけど
本当は薬飲ませちゃってと
いい加減大騒ぎするんだからとか言いたかったんですけど
別に言う必要ないんだから
ああ そうですかね じゃあしょうがないと
明日ぐらいになるともう大丈夫やと
明日また大丈夫で ものすごい大騒ぎしていたんですけど
だからこの薬で抑えることがリラックスではないと
その年 すごい年取っていた
もうこの現代知識何もない
そのお坊さんさえも知ってるんですね
やっぱりこれが強引なやり方で
体の機能を抑えているだけではないかと
だから体の機能を抑えることはリラックスではないんです
だから決して精神安定剤などなどではリラクゼーションはできません
あれで機能そのものを抑えるんです
ですから 病気で問題持っている人にはいいかもしれません
それは病気ですからね
だからリラクゼーションというのは何のためかというと
見事に成功するためにあるものなんですよ
物事 まあ成功と言えば大げさですけど
やっぱり自分の仕事は完全にこなすために失敗しないでやらなくちゃいけないことはきちんとこなすための手段なんですよ
だから このいい加減にのんびりと強い意味ではありません
それをまず覚えておいてください
そうするとリラックスできると思います
だから リラックスの意味わかってないんだからね
リラックスというのは
なんかどこかで腰をかけて
まあおどおどして居眠りしながら
そういうことじゃないんですよ
せんべい食べてお茶飲みながら
まあ例えばこのダラダラするとかね
気が緩んでるとかね ボーっとしている
こういうものもリラックスだと思っていることがあります
大体ほとんどそういうふうに思ってるんですね
まあボーっとしてる リラックスしているんだよと
ではないんです で 証拠があります
まず ボーっとしていることで
自分でやらなくてはいけない
そのその瞬間にやる仕事できますかね
私たちの目が覚めた時からまた寝る時まで
いろんなことをやらなくちゃいけないんですよ
何もやらずにいるわけにはいきません
では ボーっとしている時は何ができるんですかと
何もできないでしょうに
それで何もできない状態でいるということは
リラックス状態ですかね
これは硬直している状態ですよ
だから本当はこのダラダラしていることもものすごい緊張なんですよ
すごいストレスとストレスなんですね
ストレスですね 英語の発音で言えばね
ものすごいストレス状態なんです
ダラダラしている時 で
気が緩んでいる時も同じことです
できなくて気が緩んでいるんですよ
だから普通は緊張して仕事をしている人よりも
このダラダラしている人がものすごいストレスかかっているんです
で 結果見えます 体も心も壊れるんだから
後でかなり悪い結果になるんだから
例えば 1 日ぐらい休みの日とかね
もうダラダラしてみて下さい
いかに気持ち悪いかと
その一日中ダラダラしていて
結果として得られる気持ち悪さは
一日仕事をして疲れてくる
気持ち悪さよりはもうかなり多いんですよ
一日中仕事をして疲れて
もういきなりもう倒れて寝てしまって
また朝起きると すごく気分がいいんですよ
1年中も緊張感でストレスでいたんだよと
でもそのストレスが仕事終わった途端
もう消えてしまうんですね
ほっとするんですよ まあ終わりましたと
では寝るぞということになるんですよ
しかし  1日ダラダラしちゃうとそう簡単じゃないんですね
そのストレスを解散する方法もなかなか見つからない
どんどん悪化していけちゃうんですね
脳の機能がさらに低下して
さらに仕事を体動かせなくなっちゃって
そうするとさらにもう低下していき機能が
で 悪循環になります ですから
決してストレス いわゆるリラックスするということは
ダラダラすることでも
気が緩むことでも ボーっとしてることでもないんです
だから定義に戻りますけど
円滑に ものすごくスムーズに
その瞬間 その瞬間の仕事を捗られるような体と心のコンディション
それがリラックスなんですね
ですから リラックスというものが仕事をするためのものであって
働くためのものであって
のんびりするためのものではありません
これから頑張るんだからリラックスしますと
皆さんはかなり聞いてもう覚えていると思いますけど
仏教っていうのは こののんびりすることっていうのはものすごい大嫌いだからね
お釈迦様なんかはもう怒鳴るんだから
ある人がインターネットでね
あの 寝て瞑想する方法を教えてくださいと
教えてあげたってもどうったことないんだけど
私はものすごく怒ったんです
その質問には すごく厳しく返事を書いたんですよ
それがあれば大変ありがたいんだと
そうすると 朝やりたいことをやって
昼もやりたい放題なことをやって
遊びたい放題遊んで お風呂にも入って寝た
寝たところで もう修行オートモードで
それで朝目が覚めてみると
もう悟ってるんではないかと
そういう方法あれば大変ありがたいんですけど
私も教えてもらいたいんだよと
だからそれはなんとなく丁寧に書いているようなんですけど
とんでもない侮辱で書いているんです
裏を読んでみると 言葉の
すごく優しく そういう方法あれば本当にありがたいことで
こちらも勉強してみたいもんだなとかね
きつくもないしね 結局裏を読んでみると
相手をもうものすごい侮辱しているんです
で それにまあそんな方法はありませんと
寝てやる方法っていうのは
寝たら何も得られませんと
僕は寝ることさえ嫌がるんだよと
世の中の人々はもう寝ることは大変必要で
ブッダはそう思ってないんだよと言って
偈一つ引用しておいたんです
頭に火がついているような感じで
矢にやられているような感じで
寝ないで頑張りなさいというお釈迦様の言葉があるんです
それを書いて それを返事として
しかし この間 京都の瞑想会で
すごい年上のおば様が
まあすごくみんなと仲良く一生懸命瞑想していて
で 終わりの時は前の日か覚えてないんですけど
自分がね 体も弱くて 皆様と一緒にもう合わせてやるというところはかなり難しいし
ですから体すごくもう疲れてこうなる場合は
やっぱりまあ横になりたくはなりますよと
で その時は何か瞑想する方法ないんでしょうかと聞いたら
何のことなく教えたんです
こういう風に こういう風に
こういう風にしてくださいと
もうたった 1 分以内で
その瞬間であの答えが思い出したんですよ
だから ある人にそういう風に返事出したんだけど
そのおば様には あ それだったらそれはその通りでしょうと
もう体いじめてはいけませんと
無理をしてはいけませんと
疲れたら適当に横になってくださいと
横になってから こういう風に
こういう風に この子のやり方でやってくださいと
すぐもう 1 分以内でとにかく説明したんですね
その方はもう大変もう感謝したんですから
よくわかりました ありがとうございます
だから別に横になって瞑想できないわけでもない
できる方法もあるんだけど
聞くなよ そんなこと 聞いた時点でもうダメですね
それなんですよ だから仏教はすごい
この怠けにのんびりすることにすごい反対んですよ
逆にあんたがのんびりする暇があるのかと
怠けて時間無駄に使う
無駄に使う時間あるんですかと
秒も惜しんでなさいよと
それが仏教的な生き方なんですよ
でもそれ聞いちゃうとまた誤解しちゃうんですね
まあ緊張して神経は硬直して
もうとにかくなんとかやると
だからそこら辺でもっと勉強しなくちゃいけない
普通の俗世間で我々は何のために頑張っているかというと
貪瞋痴のために 怒りのために
欲のために 見えのために
まあそういうもう役に立たない何かのために必死になっている
だからその上 秒も惜しんで頑張りなさいと言ったら
その人はもう はあ もうやれやれという気持ちになるんですよ
1 日 10時間ぐらい仕事に踏ん張っていて
ものすごい疲れているのに
もっと仕事をしろと言われると
もうできるわけないんだよという
だからそんなことを言っているわけでもないんだ
だからこの金儲けやら商売やら
もうそういうね 家の掃除やら
もうそんなもんにもう秒も惜しんで頑張りなさいと言っていることじゃないんですよ
そんなことで必死になって苦労して
もうもう体がもう過労して倒れるまでやったっても
もう結果ってどんな結果ですかと
すぐ寸時に消える結果でしょうに
ものすごい緊張して もう料理作ったっても
まあ 5 分 10 分以内でもう全部消えてしまう結果だからね
だからそういうことではないんですね
やっぱり やっぱり自分の人生として
瞬間瞬間意味のあることをしなくちゃいけない
そういう仕事は 2種類ありますよ
どうしてもやらなくてはいけないこと
それもそういう意味があるんですよ
汚れている部屋はまあ掃除をする
掃除する それはどうしてもやらなくちゃいけないことで
それ一つやらなくちゃいけないこと
そんなのは文句言ったっても何の意味もないんだから
やらなくちゃいけないんだから
そういうものは後回しには絶対しないで
そんな暇がないんだと
やらなくちゃいけない仕事はあるんだと
それは淡々とやる それで残り時間どうしますかと
それでダラダラする それはもう最悪なんですね
やっぱりダラダラする時間ないんですよ
いつでも自分のために何かプラスになるもの
自分の心 仏教ではっきり言えば
自分の人格 心を成長するものを清らかになること方向へ努力しなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうことだから 仏教は決してこの怠けたり
だらだらしたり のんびりしたり
物事を後回しにするということは
もう最悪な生き方やと
ものすごく批判 批判ではなくて非難までしているんです
人はなんで堕落するんですかと
堕落する道を何なのかと聞いたところで
お釈迦様はそういうことをリストアップして言ってるんですよね
怠け者で朝寝坊するやと
欲張りでもいろんな邪な行動をするとかね
それですぐ怒るんだとかね
それからよくこの 何て言いますか
この喋る いろんな人とあれやこれやとか
喋るわ喋るわ喋るわ よくみんな喋ることに
無駄話にもかなり時間なくなっちゃいますよ
だからこのちょっと時間があったら友達を呼んで喋っている
今は家に呼べない 呼べないんだからね
電話であれやこれやとかね
あれ 仏教はもうダメやと
携帯持ってても歩けないし
階段は登れないし そちらはいいんだけど
この他の人々にどれほど迷惑かと
一番危険なのはこのエスカレーターでもやってるんですね
あれほど大事な仕事はあるんですかと
だからどんどん頭が悪くなっちゃいますよ
ただメール送るんだからね
お元気？とかね 今新宿のエスカレーターにいるよとかね
もうどういう結果になるかとね
それで早く打てるんだと
それまた自慢したりとかね
だからそういうこの道が間違ってるんだから
私は未だに使おうと思ったことはないんですよ
だからあった方が便利ということもないわけでもないんですよ
突然連絡何かとかね あった場合は
まあポケットの中に電話があれば
これはものすごい最高の便利ですよ
でも持っただけで気持ち悪くなっちゃうんですよ
あれはイメージが映っちゃいますから
現代人の あんなに恐ろしい堕落する道をやるべきかと
やらなくても なんとなくまあ人にものを言えた状態でなくなっちゃいますよ
まあどうせ自分も自分の性格知ってるんだから
やっぱりそんなもの買っちゃうと弄るんだからね
買ってしまっちゃうと壊れるまでいじるのは
それはもうもう知ってます
あ 壊れちゃったと 最後にということになるし
まあですから そういうのはこのパーリ経典にはないんですよ
携帯電話で無駄話するなよとかね
あるかと聞いたってもないんですよ
しかし このニッダーシーリサバーシーリ
寝ることは好きで好きで
サバーシーリ 人々と何とか何とか喋ること
コミュニケーション取りことは好きで好きでとかね
それだったらもう堕落するんだよと
ですから この時間を無駄に使うということは
仏教ではもう大反対はっきりしています
なんかこの年取ってくると
あまり仏教なんか勉強してない人々は
なんかもう日本のお寺なんかにでのんびり旅をして
それが修行やと どこかの旅館でご飯食べて
仲間でいろいろ喋って
はっ ありがたいお寺さんだとかね
それでそこからハンコなんかもらって
また次のお寺に行ってとかね
他のやること何も知らんからね
それで十分ですが 本当はもっと立派なことはありますよ
やろうとすれば やっぱり死ぬ瞬間までやることはものすごく着々とあります
お釈迦様が推薦しているのは
もう馬鹿もできたところで
馬鹿ももうどんどん大きくなって
自分にはやることなくなっちゃうと
とことん真理を聞きなさいよと
今までもう金儲かることで必死でしたし
家守ることに必死で もう用がなくなっちゃったんだから
それからでも遅くないんだから
自分の人生のためになることをやりなさい
だから仏教の真理を聞いたり聞くと
まずわからないのは決まってるし
そうするとやっぱり悔しくなって
とにかく理解してみるぞとかね
で わからないところはいろんな知ってる人々と話し合って話し合って
だから無駄話は真理のディスカッションに使うようにお釈迦様はしているんですよ
どうすれば怒りってなくなるんでしょうか？とかね
いろいろ悩みあるあるんですけどね
なんで人が悩むんでしょうかねとかね
そういうことを喋ってみると
自分の勉強になりますよ
だから死ぬまでやることはいっぱいあるんです
なのに えんらく時間無駄
無駄に使う です で そういう世界でリラックスの話なんです
そこで一般的に聞いちゃうと
そんな話しちゃうと 仏教っていうのは緊張一筋ではないかと
あの頭 髪の毛に火がついた
服に火がついたような感じで頑張りなさいと言えば
もうこれはもう緊張そのものではないかと
この教えは と勘違いするかもしれませんだけど
でもブッダは真理を言ってるんですよ
ブッダの世界でちゃんとリラックスということは考えているんです
それが前に言った通り
その瞬間 その瞬間 我々にはやらなくちゃいけない仕事があります
それがうまく あと後悔しないように
失敗しないようにこなすと
今の時間考えてみると
皆様の仕事は私の話を聞くことです
たとえ嫌でも 嫌だったら出て行けばいいんだからね
座ってるんだったら聞くしかないんですよ
それだったらリラックスして聞くということは
ちゃんと話を理解するということなんです
理解して覚えてまでおく
それに邪魔になるものはストレスなんですよ
例えば こちらで体だけ座っていて
頭が別なところにある
頭で別なことを考えていると
もうストレス状態なんですよ
イライラします そうすると
試しにやってみてください
自分の明日の仕事のことを明日どうしようかとかね
明日仕事ないか 明後日の仕事のこととかね
考えながら 家のことを考えながら
あるいは別なことを考えながら
落書きでもしながら聞いてみてください
すっごく嫌になるんじゃないんですか？なんかまだ続けてますかね
その話は とかね 早く終わってくれないかとか
その気持ちになるんですよ
これがストレスのもう赤
赤いところまでもうメーターが上がってるんです
だからこういう場合でも
我々は緊張して硬直になってストレスかかる時もあるし
ストレスかかったら話は心には入りません
だからテープレコーダーで記録しておこうと
かなり自然破壊と時間の無駄で
そういう人はテープレコーダーで持っていて
後で聞くかというと 私はどうかなと
こちらで 2時間半以上喋って
3時間ぐらい喋るものはね
後で聞くとまた 3時間取るでしょうに
それで損か得かと 時間的には
話を聞くことができなかった人にも聞かせ
だったら それは有意義な意味のある行為で
今の ３時間は何も聞かないで後で聞くそうと言えば
だから今の時間仕事をしない人は
今の時間は仕事をしない
でしょ だから聞くわけはないんですよ
その時は今の時間だからね
悪いことに 今の時間で仕事をしないんだから
では 時間もあったことで
この間取ったテープを聞こうではないかと言ったら
その時テープを聞かなくちゃいけないでしょ
その時頭は別のところに行くんです
だから その問題は解決しません
だから 何て言いますか
今の時間でリラックスしていると
すごく時間は有効に使ったことになります
ダラダラしたことにならないんです
そうすると後で考えたっても後悔にはなりません
話は覚えている だからみんなこの記憶力術やらね
うまく勉強すること 方法とかね
もう結構商売は流行ってますけどね
で 何なのかと なんでそんなにみんなものは忘れるんでしょうかと
リラックスしていないんですよ
リラックスしていると忘れません
聞いたことを覚えています
勉強も覚えているんです
だからこのリラックスの仕方なんですよ
このリラックスの仕方
ちゃんとその場でその場でそれは変わりますから
正しく理解して 今の時間でこの仕事だから
この仕事はどうすればうまくいくんでしょうかと
例えば ちゃんとリラックスして話を聞く人が
たとえその道路でものすごい大きな事故が起きちゃって
すごい音が出たとしても
こういう風にはしません
首を曲げて見ようとはしない
そう リラックス状態なんです
のんびりしているわけじゃないんです
大事な そちらには興味がないということになっちゃうんです
周りに何が起きているかとわからなくなっちゃいます
その時はちゃんと自分の仕事をしている
周りに何が起きても 私たちにとっては自分の仕事をするしかないでしょうに
例えば事故 車が人をはねてもう跳ねた跳ねたとする道路で
なんでそこをうろうろうろうろ首を伸ばしたりして見るんですかね
自分に関係ないことで
時間なくなるだけで それでもって何か勉強してたかと
全然勉強してない ただ噂の種になるだけ
噂話の無駄話の で 論理的にどう考えたっても
私という個人が 周りは何が起きても
宇宙の裏側で何が起きても
自分にとっては今の目の前にある仕事をするしか何もできないんですよ
それ以外生き方はないんです
ですから 目の前にある仕事をしましょうと
それからある時間があって
世界の出来事を理解する時間やとだったら
それはその時の仕事ですよ
その時は地球の裏側で何が起きたかと知ればいいんです
ですから 遊ぶときは それはその時の仕事で
ニュースを聞くときは
それはその時の仕事で
これちゃんとやると 聞く時間は無駄にならないんですよ
例えば ニュースを聞く時間でちゃんとニュースを聞いて理解しておく
そうすると ずっとニュースを 24時間も聞いたりする必要はないんです
こういうこういう出来事が起きます
もう知っている ちょっと音楽を聴いて楽しもうと思ったら
それはちゃんとやる そうすると
もしかすると 15分でも 30分でも十分やってことになるはずなんですよ
これ ずっと聞いても十分じゃないんだから
結局は聞いてないんですよ
だから時間は無駄になくなりますね
では ポイントはこういうポイント
リラックスというのは
仕事をするためにあるものであって
のんびりするためのものではありません
だから リラックスしている人が
常にリラックス状態にいる人が
あの...ずっと人生は成功する
法則は同じだから 瞑想にしたっても同じことで
お釈迦様は自分の弟子たちがきちんとリラックスして
仕事をしているかないかところはかなり監視はしていたんです
修行そのものっていうのは一人でやりますけど
周りのコンディションのをね
よく感じているんですよ
いくつかケースありますけどね
例えばもう栄養失調になっているとかね
出家だからね もらったものを何か食べて
だからあまり真面目な人々というのは
もうそんなたくさん托鉢に行くよりは
その時間でも修行しますよと言って
ほんの家に二 三軒ぐらいに托鉢して
それでもらったものでもう食べて
でもすごい栄養足りなくなっちゃって
栄養失調状態になる ある面では真面目で本当に素晴らしい人なんですけど
しかし体の状態が良くない
そうすると自分の仕事は結局はできなくなる
だから 俗世間の目ではお釈迦様は見ない
普通の俗世間の人から見れば
あのお坊さんは大変立派な方で
大変真面目な方で 適量にご飯をいただいてもいただかなくても
家二 三軒にしか托鉢に行かないんだと
それで早くも寺に戻って
そのご飯を食べて修行にかかっているんだと
立派やと それにしてみれば
あのお坊さんはもう十五軒も歩いたんだよといいよと
と俗世間で言うかもしれません
で お釈迦様はそうは見ないんです
別な計算をするんです
この人は真面目ということは誤解して
あまり十分栄養は取っていない
それで体のコンディションが壊れる
脳も体も機能しなくなる
結局 体が堕落 堕落じゃなくてだるくなる
そうすると瞑想したっても
もうしたんですということで終わる
結果はなしと では 修行
修行していない人と同じことになるんですね
何も結果もないんだ だったら修行してない人も何の結果もないんだからね
だから無駄ですと そんなことはと
それでお釈迦様はやっぱり十分...栄養を取れるようにはします
もうお釈迦様は別にご飯持ってくるわけじゃないんだけど
お釈迦様は場所を変え
変えさせて あんたそちらでいてはいけませんと
こういうこういうところに行きなさいよと
自由だから 全く別な場所に行かす
そう お釈迦様が決めて行かせたところで
結構食べ物は豊富で 軽々と入ると
それで健康的になって
まあ修行は成功すると
だから ああいう風に真面目さっていうことも
結果が悪ければ もうダメなんですよ
それもストレスになっちゃうんですよ
ストレスかかってやりすぎになる
だからリラックスしているかいないかということは
簡単に結果でわかるんですよ
どうやればリラックスするかっていう問題ですからね
だからなんで硬直するんですか？とかね
なんで筋肉も心も強張るんでしょうか？とかね
そこら辺原因を理解した方がいいんです
えーと 次のポイントに入っちゃうと結構時間がなくなります
あの物質をちょっと考えてみると
あの 不純物が入るとすごく硬くなってしまって
役に立たないような 物質の世界でいろいろなものがあるんですね
例えば金にしたってもね
不純物がいっぱい入っていると金でなくなっちゃいますからね
役に立たないんですよ
金脈なんか見つけてもう掘っても
ただの土だからね  １トンぐらい掘ったところで
まあせいぜい １１００グラムぐらいの金があったとかね
それぐらいもないぐらいですからね
だから １点の １トンの土には全然価値がない
だから不純物が入っても
で 役に立たない 硬くなるものもあって
不純物のおかげで柔らかくなるものもあります
柔らかくしたければいろいろ不純物を入れる
両方もあります まあいろんなもうこのもう世の中でね
いろんなものを作る時はあるでしょうしね
ただ単純なゴムにしたっても
ゴムが硬い方がいい場合は何か不純物を入れる
すごく伸びる柔らかさで欲しい場合はまた別なことを入れるとかね
金属の場合も同じでしょうし
金属はすごく硬く曲げ曲げたら困る場合のなんとか金属ありますね
同じ鉄ですけど すごい硬くて
その場合は入れる不純物とすごくいつでも曲げ曲げることできるように
鉄を作る場合は別なものを入れたりすると
まあ例えばこのバネとかね
そういう場合は筋肉 まあ鉄はいつでも伸びたり縮んだり
伸びたり縮んだりする
壊れたりはしません しかし
英語でカーストアインという鉄がありますよ
日本語で何か分かりませんですけど
かなり硬い それで何かある
ある特定の形を作る それがその形でずっとあってほしい
エンジンの周りの ものはカーストアインなんですね
それがしっかり硬くて
形は絶対変えてはいけません
その形でいくら暖かくなっても伸びてはいけません
そこら辺はカーストアインというやり方でもう作っちゃうんで
カーストという言葉も形は一旦取った
取ったら終わりという意味なんですよ
しかし 同じ車に使う他の鉄はそれでは困りますよ
動いたり曲げたり また元に戻ったりしないと
だから同じ鉄考えたっても
不純物によって硬くなったり
柔らかくなったりする
で 同じ法則 心にも入りますよ
ある不純物入ると心は硬くなって硬直して
しまいます 役に立ちません
悪いことには使えますけど
それで別な不純物入っちゃうとあまりにももろくて
いわゆるダラダラ状態になる
どちらにもしない もう立たせ置いたっても
こちらに曲げたり こちらに曲げたりとかね
心にもその両方あります
本当はそのどちらでも
硬すぎ状態も この柔らかすぎ状態もリラックスではないんですよ
リラックスというのは
そのその仕事に合わせて硬さか柔らかさという調整なんですよ
それで まあ心の場合は不純物という言葉を使いますが
あの科学の世界では不純物とは言わないでしょう
結局は合成するものだからね
そういうことで この心はの合成
どんなものと合成するかという
それで不純物は仏教では別にはっきりしてあって
不純物がいくつかあります
そのそれが入っちゃうと心は硬くなる
その硬くなった心は人殺しに戦争をするために
銀行強盗に殺戮のためには使います
他何にも使えません もうめげない
で この間 このテレビでちょっと見たんですが
もうなんで私は全部見ていないんで
ほんのちょっとちょっとしか見ないんです
もう全部ちゃんと全部回しますからね
この総連というかね  ソ連連邦がこのロシア連邦ですかね
ラッシャンフェデレーションで
このいろいろこのテロというか
このテロたちの情報をね
かなり明確に集めるという集めて
まあアメリカにもそういうスパイ情報とか
それは提供しているみたいですけど
アメリカはもう世界一すごいんだからね
相手にしない そんな情報は
それであの建物が壊れたところで
あ なるほどと それで認めたくない
もう前もって情報が入っていたということは認めるもない
認めたくない 攻撃されますよと
なんかプーチンさんが前もって情報報告してあったんだそうです
無視されたと  それはどうでもいいことで
私に関係ないことだからね
そこでこのチェチェンの二十歳ぐらいの女の子二人が自爆するために
それ全部ビデオクリップあるんですね
で やっぱりこのその人々は神のためにあなたは選びましたとかね
この人殺しが言うんだからね
ではあんた体中爆弾を巻いて爆破しなさいと
で それが後の人々を訓練するために全部ビデオを撮る
テロたちが そこでその車にもビデオをちゃんとつく
車は爆弾いっぱい それで車の前のシートにこのバッテリーがあって
で それでかなり可愛い
もう綺麗な女の子 娘二人でしたけどね
またインタビューされる
インタビューされる時は
まあ私は選ばれたことは神に感謝しますと
死ぬことは何のこともないんだと
この世の中の生命っていうのは全然意味はないんだと
本当の命っていうのは天国の命やと
だからこの世界っていうのはもう仮なものやと
一時的なものだと だからいつ死んだっても
それは全然関係ないと
なぜならば 神様は素晴らしい命を我々のために用意しているんだから
という話をする それで天国に行ったら
早くも先に行った友達にも会えると
あの頭の中でその思考しかないんですよ
その思考しかない それで自分を選んだのは神か誰かのテロの組織のリーダーかね
はっきり言うと そこら辺にいるとくぐ普通の人殺しやでしょうに
怒りに狂ってる人々でしょうに
だからといって誤解して欲しくない
その人々はもうただ病気で怒っているわけではないんだよ
原因なくくて怒らないんだからね
それなりの侮辱されて
それで怒ってるんですよ
それも認めてあげなくちゃいけないんですよ
テロのリーダーでも もうカンカン怒って怒りに狂っているのは
ただ自動的に怒ったってわけじゃないんです
もう我慢できんほどいろんな差別があって
それで怒っている それも認めてあげなくちゃいけない
そうでないと慈悲になりませんだからね
とにかくそういう人々はもう怒りに狂って狂って狂って
君と君 君に生きなさいよと
選ぶ手段というのは疑わられ
疑えない あの女の二人見ても
もうこの世の中誰も疑わないと思いますよ
ものすごい可愛い娘二人で
またまだ年下で 車なんか運転するってもすごい可愛いんですよ
まだまだそんな年でもないという
なんかまあ歳はちょっと取っただけぐらいのね
だからそれほど何て言いますか
居心地ないというかね
もうハンドルの取り方でもね
見るとなんとなくまあ可愛くてな
頑張ってるなという優しい気持ちに誰でもなっちゃいますよ
それで選ぶんだからね
別に精神的なところで選んだわけじゃない
いかに人を騙せる方法
それで人を殺しに行く
人を殺しに行って天国に生まれ変われるんだよとまた信じてもいる
だからそれはもう片やでは考えてます
もし我々にその人が自爆テロを落とす起こす前に会ったとしたら
教えてあげることはできますかと
いくら踏ん張ってもできないんですよ
もうすっごく他の思考はできないように
もう脳を不純物を入れて入れて
怒りに苦しみ 怒りに苦しみ
入れて入れて入れて もう硬くさせているんですよ
その人々は神を信じているかというと全くないんですよ
神を侮辱しているんですよ
神や神やとか言うんだけどね
だからその宗教から見ても
地獄に行くことは決まってるんです
仏教からではなくて なぜならば
人間というのは神さんが作ったもんでしょうに
私たちにはあれやこれやという権利ないでしょうに
神様がせっかく大事に作って育て上げた人間を無差別に殺して
では神様 私のことをよろしくお願いしますと
神様から見れば大きな誤りでしょうに
それぐらいのことを神様にできるでしょうに
地球の管理ぐらいは どこかであの
例えばイスラムの人々をね
あまり差別されちゃって
まあちょっとなんとかしたんだからと言ってね
それで世界は破壊になるわけじゃないし
まあとにかく まあ自分の教えにも逆らっていることは当然でしょうし
それでも気がつかないんですよ
神を信仰してないんだと
自分たちは だから そのなんでその例を出したかというと
あれぐらいもう元気で明るくて
遊んで笑いながら 1 日生活する
もう年頃の女の子たちがね
もう合わないんですよ
このあの爆弾のあの捨てるところまでビデオがあったんですよ
それで あの そういうソ連の軍隊のところに行って
あの自分で手でこの電気をバッテリーにつなげると
そこからはない 真っ黒
だから この心に不純物が入っちゃうと硬くなる
仕事にはなりません それは人殺しなどには使える
それから心は何かぬるぬるする
もうどちらにもならない
例えば粘土でもなんかもうスプーンですくえるようにぐらい粘土を溶かしちゃうと何もできないでしょうに
塗るぐらいはできますけど
粘土で何か作るんだよと思ったら
粘土が乾いたらまるっきりできないし
すると粘土には適当な水を入れて練って練って
まあ品物をいろいろ作るんでしょうに
そこでその水入れすぎになると何も仕事になりません
さて 心にもこの怠け あれこれ疑うこと
はっきりしないこととかね
後悔すること 落ち込むことなどの不純物が入っちゃうと
もう役に立ちません 立てない
もう何て言いますか 柔らかすぎ
で たくさん教えているのは
この心を硬くする不純物も
溶けてしまう 柔らかくする不純物も
すべて取っ払いなさいと
綺麗に綺麗な心しなさいと
それで その綺麗な心に他の要素というか
他のものは適当に合わせる
いわゆるこの科学的な
いろんな鉄やらいろんな品物を作る場合は
あれ いろんなものを調合するんですね
同じプラスチックにしたっても
あの 同じじゃないですよ
そのその内容が違いますからね
もうたくさんプラスチック
ビニール製品が我々使っているでしょうに
しかし やっぱりそれぞれ違いますよ
かなり硬く 硬い家具なんかにも使うプラスチックもありますし
それからあれ あのサランラップみたいにあまりにも柔らかくて
あの食べ物やら拭いておくために包装するために使うものもあるし
でもサランラップにしたっても
すごく薄くて柔らかいでしょう
でもかなり頑丈でしょうね
だから仕事になってますよ
きちんと折れる 切れる
しかし あまりにも薄いんだから
ちょっとでも二枚 ちょっと潰す
もうなんか重ねちゃうともう使えない
それぐらい柔らかい 開けたり広げたりしたりできません
しかし あんなに柔らかいものはちゃんと皿の上に入れて電子レンジに入れちゃうと
全然もう何のことなくしっかりと
変化することはなく そこで普通はあのー
コンビニで売ってるあのプラスチックの容器に入れている食べ物なんかは
電子レンジ入れて回しちゃうとギュッと縮んじゃうんですね
やっぱり熱にすごい弱い
だからそれがすごくいいコンディションですよ
それをその品物によっても
サランラップは柔らかいんだけど
仕事を自分の仕事には必要な硬さを持っている
食べ物を入れる容器はかなり厚くて
結構大丈夫なんですけど
電子レンジ入れちゃうとギュッともう曲げてしまっちゃって
また漏れちゃうとレンジまで汚れるということもあります
サランラップより厚いんですよ
だからこの工業の世界では
このどのようにこの物質を入れるかと
どんな調整するかということは明確に計算してやっています
それで我々心も同じく不純物は全くダメやと捨ててしまって
いろんな要素を心に合わせるんですよ
合わせてその場のその場の仕事をするんです
それがリラックスという世界なんです
では 時間すごく伸びてしまって
ちょっと休憩いたします
では始まります そこで心に不純物が入って硬くなった場合はね
硬直した場合は なんで硬直するかというと
不純物って何なのかと
で あの 前言ったのは この心が硬くなると
まあ人殺しぐらいしかできんと
銀行強盗しかできんと
あまりにも病気で もう人間じゃないんですよ
もう人間だと思ってもダメなんですよ
人間ではないんですよ
恐ろしい しかし 我々はそんなことするわけじゃないし
我々はそんなに誰かにマインドコントロールされているわけでもない
しかし 私たちの心も硬くはなります
体も心も硬直するはことはあります
その時私たちはどうしますかと
まあ人殺しに行かないのはわかりますけど
たまにないわけでもないんですけど
あの やっぱりその原因っていうのはね
見栄とか怒りとか弱みなんですね
心の中で見栄という不純物が入っています
中でゴチャゴチャゴチャゴチャそれ回ってるんですよ
それで何か仕事しなくちゃいけない
あんたこの仕事してくださいと頼まれる
頼まれた瞬間で 仕事と心一緒にならなくちゃいけないんだから
この見栄という不純物が入ってるんだから
仕事を見たところでいきなり硬くなってしまう
なぜならば これ失敗しちゃった
自分どうしますか？だから見栄とすごく働きますね
それから怒り 怒っているとどうしても硬くなるんですね
仕事を出した時点でやりたくない
嫌やと仕事に怒っても
仕事をした 頼んだ人に怒っても
もうできなくなっちゃうんですね
すごい硬くなってしまう
で そういう弱み できるわけないと
難しいよと こんなできませんと
できませんだけど これやらなくちゃいけないと
ということで もう硬くなって
結局はやらなくちゃいけないことになっちゃうんですね
弱みっていろいろあります
本当に仕事は慣れてないわ
勉強していないとかね
弱みっていつでもあるということでもないんです
例えば できる仕事なのに準備がしていないということもあります
例えばこのよく英語を喋れる人がいるんですよ
しかし 実際 何か英語を喋らなくちゃあかん場になってくると
英語全然わからない人はなんとか喋っているのに
もう何一つも言葉が出てこなくなって硬直してしまっちゃうんです
弱いんですよ 勉強しているのにも関わらず
それはなんでその弱みが出てくるかというと
やっぱり準備足りない
だからかなり練習して
気楽に言葉が出るようにとしておかないとね
だから本当にプロで仕事できる人でも硬直するときがあります
それはその仕事に必要な訓練やら準備やらしていないんだからなんですね
わかりやすく言えば 野球選手とかね
まあ上手だから選ばれてるし
これは問題はない しかし
毎日の訓練をちゃんとやってないと
もう球を見るのはもう怖いんですよ
もう硬くなっちゃうんですよ
バッター あのバットが動かなくなっちゃうんです
振りが微妙に遅くなるんですよ
その 0.01 秒はもう全部終わりですから
その遅くなること だからプロだからといってではなくて
その野球の場合はずっともう手やら足やら打ち事やら取ることやら
何でも訓練 訓練 準備をしてコンディションを保たないと
だから準備足らなくなっちゃうとも
みんな硬直してしまっちゃうんです
とにかく自分の高慢とやらプライドやらいろいろありますけどね
まあわかりやすいことでいちいち言う必要はないんですね
まあ高慢があると やっぱり仕事出てくると
やっぱり評価があるんだからね
その評価は受け止める勇気がないんですよ
高慢だから だから前もってもう硬くなってしまう
それから不純物を入って心が柔らかくなったところどうなるかと
もう組み立てないぐらいも
何て言いますか まあネバネバでヌルヌル状態で
もう使えない状態で柔らかくなってしまえば
やっぱりその人々よく見えるのはもうはっきり何も決められない
決めてもすぐ忘れちゃう
約束も忘れちゃう 例えば仕事あるにも関わらず
後にしますと言って他のことで遊んでしまう
遊んでる代わり 誰かが他のことを言ったらそちらに行く
そういう性格もありますね
それは心が弱すぎというか
あまりにも この粘土でいえば水が入れすぎだからもう使えなくなっているんですね
どちらにしたっても仕事はできない
体心が硬くなっても そうかって
あまりにも溶ける 溶けているような状態になっても仕事になりません
リラックス状態ではありません
それから 一般的にはみんな誰にも経験あると思いますけど
真剣に仕事をしようと思うと
やっぱり結構ストレスでやってるんですよ
それはいろんな人の話も聞いたことありますけど
やっぱりストレスというのは人間に必要ですよと
でないと何一つもできなくなるんだよと
だから医者から誰からまででも
やっぱりかなり緊張感があって
仕事をする 電車の運転手としてもね
毎日同じことだから やっぱりのんびりと行っちゃうと大変危険だからね
やっぱりいろんな工夫をして
この緊張感をね いわゆるストレスをわざと作る場合ありますよ
とか いろんな会社 どんな会社でもそれやってます
とことん緊張させて仕事に出す
でないとすぐ仕事を失敗しちゃうと
それでみんなちゃんと仕事をしていますよ
軍隊でも警察でも電車でもどこでも仕事に出たら
もう会社に行くのは前もって行くんだけど
自分の仕事順番来るんだから
その時は緊張させちゃう
指導する 命令する人 で
なんでかというと まあ君行って
じゃあまあ今もう30分で
あんた新幹線だから じゃあ行ってくださいと言っちゃうとダメですよ
だからテレビで見たんですけど
ものすごく決まってる時間で
秒単位で来て ものすごい大きい声で報告する
何々さん この時間でまいりますと
それで返事するけれども
はい わかりました なんとか言って
それで新幹線の運転にも道具を持っていく時でも
ものすごい緊張というかね
やっぱり緊張させて仕事をさせちゃうんですね
それは何のためかというと
このやっぱりちゃんと仕事してほしいんですよ
事故なんか起こしちゃったら困りますからね
そういうわけで ほとんどの人々はこの緊張感があった上で仕事をするということも当然世の中であります
ですからね ストレスというのは避けられないんだと
そこでリラックスわからないんだからそうなってますよ
そういう人々は リラックスというのはダラダラすることだと思ってるんですよ
だから緊張させちゃう
それでこう思えばどうですかね
やっぱりそれだったら
ストレスかかっても すごいストレスであっても
緊張でももうすごいきつくても
いい仕事をしているんではないかと
ちゃんと仕事できるんではないかと
という論理にもなります
そうしなきゃ仕事できませんよと
飛行機の操縦士とかにはね
何時間も一応オートパイロットモードにするまではね
ものすごい緊張でいないと
それでオートパイロットしたっても
やっぱり着陸するまでは
生きるか死ぬかってぐらいの
やっぱり緊張感があるんですよ
でないとダメじゃないかな
まあそれ言えばそういうことなんですけど
結局仕事して苦しいんですよ
その場合は はぁ 終わったって気持ちになるんですよ
で だから時間的にも計算してますよ
例えばもう例えば飛行機だったら
一つ行ったらそこで 1 日 2 日休ませると
あるいは時間的に行って帰ったら 2 日休みと
毎日は飛ばせませんね
飛行機の場合でも どんな仕事場合も
そうやってこの別な仕事にさせる仕事をさせるか
休ませるかとするんですよ
そういう方法しか世の中でないんですよ
ではなんで 8時間で飛行機を飛ばして
また 8時間で戻ってきて
もうずっと連続して 16時間
これは危険ですか？と
それはこういうわけだから
緊張して仕事をしているんだから苦しいんです
だから長持ちはしない
危険 それもある一定の時間でうまくいくんだけど
ある時間になったらものすごい危険
だからそこでやめてもらって
ダラダラしてもらうと
それでダラダラするのは嫌だから
また仕事に行って ちゃんと自分の時間来たら仕事に行く
そうするとまたキュッと緊張感を取ってもらうというね
まあ最悪状態 結局はね
激しいんだよ ダラダラするか
緊張のピーク見るか ダラダラしている間
緊張のピーク見るかと
だから総合的に結果は幸福というふうに言えないんですよ
それで緊張して見事な結果を出しても
本人が苦しんでいるわけなんです
それで次に仕事が来ると
前の緊張感と苦しみが覚えているんだから
仕事する前に思い出しちゃうんですね
あ またかと また完璧にやらなくちゃあかんと
それが次の仕事に影響与える
だから緊張して見事に完璧な仕事をする人にしても
いつでもそれできないんですよ
一回 二回でも三回は本人が断るか
何か何か言い訳して逃げるか
あるいはもう中途半端な仕事をするかっていうことになるんですよ
だからプロは結構失敗しますね
それからこのリラックスする場合は
まあリラックスして仕事するってことは
仕事はうまくいっている
苦しくはない 体と心のコンディションが整えているということは
仕事そのものをやるとかなり刺激というか
楽しいんですよ 他のことに心がいかない
もうかなりコンディションがいい
乗っているというかね
仕事に で その場合はリラックス状態で終わっても
あ 終わったのという感じで
はっ 終わったという感じではないんですね
やればもっとできるぞと
で 終わっても苦しくはないし
ストレス溜まってないし
では休み取っちゃうとこれまた思い存分遊べるんですよ
元気だからダラダラする必要なくなっちゃうんですね
だからすると楽しいんですよ
リラックスしてやれると
それなのに もう一つ世の中のことあるんですよ
例えば 我々っていうのは頼まれて仕事をする
誰でもそういうことだからね
自分勝手に仕事したっても
誰も関係ないしね そういう仕事になりませんしね
で なんかわからないんだけど
人に頼まれると なんか自分でやりたくないものを頼まれてるんではないかと
あるいは自分にできんことをわざと頼んでるんではないかという気がしないじゃないかなと思いますよ
時々会社の仕事する人とかね
よく言う場合で なんか自分が慣れてもないのに
もう ７年もこの仕事をやっていたのに
全く関係ないところに回されちゃって
ということで やる自信がないんですよ
今まで別の仕事に慣れているんだから
なんでこの上司がわざとこんなことを私に任せるんですかと
それまた大変緊張しちゃいますよ
今まで楽に楽しくやっていたのに
だからよくあります 世の中でなんかできそうにもない仕事を頼まれる
仕事だから こちらどうしてもやらなくちゃいけない
これが必ずしもストレス溜まっちゃいますよ
その時は そういうことで
運命的にプレッシャーをかけられる
ことがあります できんことを頼む
まあ関係あるんだけど
頼んだその仕事 その分野が自分にはできないと
私に一つ経験がありますよ
私はもうもう文字読める
読み始めた時からもう歴史はもう嫌い
どうしても勉強したくない
小学生の時でも 色々ちょっと歴史の文言というので
何やこれ？と 面白くないと
だからもうこれでもうずっと大人になるまでもそれだけはもう絶対嫌やと
それで大学に入ってから友達っていうのは
歴史のもうもう専攻 歴史やってる
何人？ 3人 4人ぐらいいたんですね
信じられない この人たちは
あんた方何やってるんだか
あれって勉強ですか？とかね
それでみんな偉そうにいろいろ何々何年何でこういうことが起きて
それで何年だから何よと
こちらはね よくもあんなくだらんことを覚えているもんだなとかね
どんな論理で覚えているんでしょうかと
だから論理がないんだからね
とにかく嫌でしたから
それで大学で仕事をしている時は
何かの発表で教授たちの間でしかしか発表しないものなんですね
仏教に関係あるものなんですけど
まるっきり仏教とスリランカの歴史に関係ある研究テーマなんです
これも歴史だっても古い歴史だったら
もうテキストはもうとっくにできているんだから
もう調べるのは簡単 現代時代になってくるとえらい難しい
特にこのイギリス時代やらポルトガル人やら
その戦略を一部一部占領されていたんだから
その時と仏教の関係やら
そこら辺はもうかなり複雑で
そこら辺あんたが書いてくださいと
冗談じゃないんですよ
これが もうこちらはもうもうアレルギー起こすんだから
ヒストリーと言っただけでも
もう嫌なんですよ 今も嫌なんです
もういろいろ説法などには霊として必要なことはわかってますけど
だからこの面白く もう漫画みたいな感じで NHK
なんかで出している歴史ところどころ見るんで
それでも嫌になっちゃうんで
なんで人殺しの話をそんなに聞かなくちゃいかんかと
よく上司に人を殺したぞというぐらいでしか読めないんですね
バカじゃないかと もっと子供の面倒見てね
子供と遊んで田んぼでもやった方がよかったのにとか
そうするとあんたの名前も誰も知らないぞとかね
なんかおかしいんですよ
それではもうストレスかかりますよ
だからこれ運命的なんですよ
で 私は本当にもうわがままだからかなり怒ったんですよ
怒る立場がないんですよ
もう仕事に就いてもう 1年も経ってなかったと思いますけどね
その学部長というかね
ものすごく怒ったんです
怒って言いたいことを言ってね
もうなんでこんなこと私は違うでしょうと
私の研究分野は嫌ですと
なんでこの人 この人選ばないんで
そういう人々はその線でやってるんではないかと
で その人って何のことなくニコニコと話を聞いて
ではしっかりやりなさい
そういうさらに腹が立って
今までこのやってはいけないことをね
もう上司というか 大学の場合
もうかなり上下関係ってすごいでしょうに
ここまでもう怖いものを知らすって感じで
それぐらいアレルギーなんですよ
クビになってもいいんだと
もう嫌やと なのに全然話さえも聞いていないという
もうさらにもう もうどうしようもなく
まあやったんですよ とにかく
まあ結果はもう誰よりもすごい
いい結果出しちゃったんだから
で まあこれでもかいという風にも
いろいろ調べて調べて調べて調べて
で まあほんの少々のレポートで少々ではなくて
それなレポートですが
だいたい必要な量よりは 4倍データ集めてレポート出しちゃったんです
結局専門家でやっていたっても
自分たちでも勉強しなきゃここら辺わからないよとかなんとかとかね
そんなもんかと私は一人勝手に威張っていたんですけど
まあで その場合は誰でもストレスかかる
それで私がどうやってやったかというと
では こんな嫌なことなのに
でもやっておけば悪くないんじゃないかと
嫌なことでもね で そこら辺で歴史のことをペラペラ喋ってる人も
たまにバカにすることもできるんじゃないかとかね
まああの大学の関係だから
お互いにいろいろ嫌味言ったりするのはまあごく普通だからね
だから歴史のことなんか言ったら
何かこちらでも言い返すことはあるんじゃないかとかね
だからまあまあ知らない世界探検するんだよとかね
もう私が解釈したんですよ
これはこの昔話の研究やと
昔々ある国である王子様がいてとかね
その王子様はこれこれでとかね
だから昔話の研究をするぞという感じで
まあもうデータを調べて調べて
その教授たちも全部いろいろまあ自分たちの研究のデータとかをくれたし
まあそれも合わせてまあ一応まあ書いて出せましたけど
まあ自分としては別にまあ新しい研究は一つミスぐらいは出なかったんですけどね
あんまり面白くなかったんですけど
それで自分がそれをチャレンジだと
新しい なんか知らなかった世界の探検やと
という気持ちになっちゃうところで
何のことなく乗ってるんですよ
もうもう周りは見えない
もうとにかく自分の仕事をやっていたんです
たまに誰かがもう喋ったっても聞こえないんです
もう頭は他のことでもう回転しているんですから
大体読んで読みながら頭の中で整理するという悪い癖がついてるんですよ
文章で書いてみて整理はしない
ですから 頭の中でいつでもガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャガチャ
整理 整理 整理 整理 整理でいい
で それで人が何か喋ったっても聞こえない
結局後で帰ってみたら
まあかなり乗っていたということなんですね
でもそれっきりにするんだよと
とにかくそれだけはという
まあできれば上司は変えて別な学校に入るぞと
こんなこと頼むんだったらという
といって学校を変えたんです
ね  時々我々にはそういうこともあります
嫌なことも頼まれる できんことを頼まれる
その時は  これがもうチャレンジやと思って
私が思ったように このもうアラジンと何とかのランプのもう研究を頼まれたんだと
面白くないでしょうね
そんなのは ではやるぞという感じでやればいいんじゃないかなと
だから できんことを頼んだ人はかえって馬鹿にして
私の態度だったらね かえって馬鹿にしているんだけど
チャレンジは受けると
だからそういう風にしないとストレスかかってしまって
硬直してしまって 結局は仕事をしなかったら大変だからね
仕事しないのは大変なことだから
やらなくちゃいかんだからね
あるいはそういう場合は
この余計な見栄を捨てて
上手なできる人にずっと聞いてもらう
本当は実はこういう仕事をやらなくちゃいかんだけど
まあどうでしょうかね
ここら辺はどうすればよろしいでしょうかとかね
聞いて回る 大体みんな聞かないんですよ
余計な態度があって 見栄があって
時々自分より後で今日入った会社に入った人でも
そこら辺で上手かもしれませんよ
その時は何のことなく
その人のところに行って
君ね こういうことを頼まれちゃっているんだけど
何もさっぱりわからないんですよと
なんかもうここら辺知ってるんだから
ちょっと教えてくれと
そうやって年は関係なく
上下は関係なく もう聞いて回っちゃえばいいんですよ
難しい仕事を頼まれたし
できないことを頼まれたし
で 聞いて回ると もう何のことなくうまくいくんで
また聞いて回ることが面白くなってくるんだから
一番早いのはやめることですけどね
この仕事はできませんですから
断りますと でもそれはできない時もありますからね
その時はそういう方法でやらなくちゃいけない
とにかくこのアドバイスを受ける人もないし
自分一人でできるわけでもないし
だったらやっぱり辞める方向で考えた方がいいんですよ
それで向こう言うんだから
実はこれできない 私に任されても仕事になりません
それでいいんですかと
それでもいいやというなら
僕は家でのんびりすればいいんです
それで困ります ちゃんの仕事だったら他の人に任せと
わざとできない人に任せるもという風に
やっぱり上司にしたっても
ちょっと勇気がないとね
言わない 言えないしね
まあどうしてもやるやる場合は
やっぱり自分の能力をね
幅をね 広げるチャンスだと思ってやってもいいんじゃないかなと
えーと それから時間がないんだから
たくさん経典はありますけど
まあ一番最後に言おうかなと思ったところがありまして
あのお釈迦様もやっぱりストレスたまったり
緊張したりしたことがあったんです
悟る前には そこはどうやって処理したんですかと
経典はあります でもこれ
残念なことにもう現代社会には合わないんですよ
それはもうそうやって
この中途半端な単純な仕事のことではないんですよ
悟る解脱の仕事の場合なんですよ
だからインドで一人もいなかったんですよ
この真理はどうやって発見するかって方法わかる人は
で まるっきり何もないところで頑張るということは
これは世界一ストレスかかる緊張する仕事なんです
お釈迦様も全財産を捨てて出て行ったんだから
負けるわけにはいきません
もうえらい頑固でしたからね
もうこれはものすごいね
お釈迦様 人の話はもう全くも聞かないんだから
で それで負けるわけにはいきませんし
プライドがあるんだから人を騙すわけにもいきませんし
だから嘘は言わないし
ここら辺で私にはこういう経験があります
経験あります それお釈迦様
そんないい加減なことはしないです
だからかなり の状態 緊張状態で痛みたいんですよ
そこら辺でどのようにこの修行をして
悟り開く道を自分が頑張ったんですかと
どのようにこのストレスを乗り越えたんですかという経典はあるんです
しかし この 皆様方に紹介しても
読んでも そこら辺は読み取れないところもありますが
あの これ恐怖感 恐怖感に関する経典と言うんですね
だからストレスやら何やらで
パーリ語ではまだこれは脅威
恐怖感っていう風にしているんです
あそこでわかる こういうこと
あの出家して修行者たちがみんなじゃあ真理発見しますと
清らかな心を作ってみますと
という意味では 出家して修行に励み
で みんなもう別に宗教ということでもないんだから
それぞれみんな自分一人一人で発見しようと思って
森の中に入っちゃう 森と言った途端
もう怖い場所なんですよ
そこからがストレスかかる
村でいて まあ歩いて歩いて
もう何キロ何十キロも歩いて
もう何もない もうただの森の中で
もう動物はいるわ インドですからね
皆様にはちょっと想像できない
私も想像できないんですけど
まあ日本は大きいんですけど
そんなに怖い恐ろしい森っていうのはないんだからね
それでもありますよ ちょっと中に入っちゃうと
もう迷子になってしまっちゃって
どこにも行けないところとかね
この富士山があったり
そこら辺にはあることは確かにありますよ
それでこのもう GPS 持っていくわけにもいきませんし
どうせそういう人々は村に戻るために目的で行くんじゃないんだから
我々は森の探検に行ったっても
GPS 持っていけばね
自分の位置をちゃんとわかるし
もう戻れるし あるいはもう遭難したっても
もうそれで信号を出しちゃえばすぐそのピンポイントして来られますけど
修行しか違うんだから
もう捨ててるんだから
森に入るということは
もう死ぬ 死ぬために行くということと同じなんですよ
だから悟るところ ところが
近寄るだけでももう緊張して
もう怯えて怖くなって
気が狂っちゃうんだと
で 釈尊が菩薩の時はそれを見ていたんですよ
せっかく人々は出家して
やるぞ 修行やるぞと言って森に入って
もう気が狂って帰ってくる
もう気が狂ってもう終わり
あるいはもう 1 日でもう怯えて帰ってくる
だからお釈迦様おっしゃっているストレスっていうのは
これもう死ぬぐらいの恐怖感のことなんですよ
皆様が感じている そんなストレスじゃないんで
髪の毛ちょっと落ちるぐらいのことっていうのは
そんな大したことないと思いますけどね
ちょっと胃潰瘍になったとかね
そんなのはもう何のことないんですよ
これ 心臓発作を起こして死ぬとか
あるいは気が狂ってしまうとかね
それどれほど緊張感かと
それぐらいの緊張感 それで釈尊も若くて出家したんですけど
一緒にいろんなやり方で頑張っている人々は一応参考にするんですよ
参考にすればするほど
こちらまた帰って あら
これどういうことかと
気が狂って帰っているのではないか
だからその森に私も入らなくちゃいかんと
だから あのお釈迦様もストレスはないっていうことなかったっていうことはいないんですよ
それ 私たち感じたものとはもう並大抵のものじゃないんです
命そのものに関係あったぐらい
しかし 見事にそれ全て乗り越えたんだ
お釈迦様はもう理性の人で
知識人で もう論理さえ論理的で科学的で
何でも分析して論理的に見る
あの森にお化けがついてそんな気にしない
人の心も抜かれちゃうぞとかね
気が狂わせる鬼が だからインドの物語いっぱいそういう物語ありますよ
ある場所に行ったら そちらにいる精霊が人の気が狂っちゃいますよと
ある場所に行ったら そちらにいるもう地縛というか
その霊がその場所から離れないようにするとかね
迷子にさせると そういう物語っていうのはものすごいあります
だからこの霊の信仰 もう心霊の信仰っていうのはすごくあるんですよ
だからブッダは認めません
そんなのはもう論理的に考える
それでお釈迦様は論理的に考えたんですよ
お釈迦様は気が狂ってくる人々のことを研究したんですよ
あるいはもう負けて 一日で怯えて帰ったとかね
1週間で怯えて帰ったとかね
もう二度とあのところには修行には入れませんよとかね
一人一人のところに行って
自分のこれから行かなくちゃいけない
だから調べたんです どういうことでしょうかと
なんかすごい科学者みたいんですよ
それでこういうことを発見したんですよ
この人々の行為 生き方
汚い アパリスッダカーヤカンマンタ
自分のいわゆる体の行為ですか
あんまりこのやり方 汚いとね
良くないと悪いと だからこんなね
性格的に悪いことばっかりしながら
また森の中に入って修行するそうと
それでみんな怖くなって
私はああいう悪いことをしたのではないか
ああいう悪いことをしたのではないか
だから この音はおそらく私を食い殺すために来る鬼の音ではないかとか思っちゃうんではないかと
だからその人調べる そういうことを言うでしょうに
私は森に瞑想していると
なんか恐ろしい鬼が後ろから来て
もう何回も倒されたんだよとかね
すごい音が来たんだよと
それでアンタどう思ったと
やっぱり私は出家しているんだけど
いろいろ悪いこともこそこそやってるんだから
おそらく神々にバレてるんだよと
だからこんなインチキできんと思って怖くなっちゃって
気が狂っちゃって帰ったんだよ
でも言うんだから あ なるほど
この人がもういろいろ悪いことをしていて
もいながら森に入って修行したときはいろいろ現象が起こると気が狂ったんではないかと
それで私はそういうインチキ的な
偽善的に目的で出家したわけじゃないし
私は隠れてでも悪いことはしないんだと
だから気にすることではありません
そのケースは私には当てはめないんだと思ったところで
自分のストレスは消えていくんですよ
もう一つは言葉が人を侮辱するは
嘘を言うわ 騙すわ 言葉の管理はしていない
出家なのに それで自分が汚れているんだから
後ろめたさがあるんだから
後ろめたさがあって入っちゃうと
まあこっちへ行ったら
みんな怖くなって 怯えて
毛が立って震えて 気が狂って
帰ってしまいますよと
それで解釈するんだと
この森の中のものは やっぱり私が口が悪いし
人は侮辱するし もうもうもういろんな嘘も言うし
まあそんなもんで この森の中にいると
まあもうやっぱりやられるのではないかと
そこにこれ順番であります
3番目はアビッジャールカーメスティッバラード
いわゆる余計に欲があるんですよ
お腹が空いた ご飯を食べたい欲はそんな余計ではないんですよ
適切な欲で 例えば有名になりたい
聖者になりたい みんなに拝められる人物になりたい
これは欲ですよ それからインドでいろいろな宗教の世界があります
自分がグルになりますと言って
女の好きな女の人何人か一緒にすごい楽しく生活しているんです
だからグルだから 先生だから
誰にも何も文句言わない
イギリスでもアメリカでもちょっとトラブったこともありますよ
このティベットのお坊さんたちがそれに乗っちゃって
いろいろ女の人を襲おうとして
あんたはあんた私のところで指導を受けてる弟子ではないかと
だから私に私はその気になったら従うのはあなたの義務ですよと
でもやっぱりヨーロッパ人がそう簡単には脅すにはめげないんだからね
ちょっと問題ケースもあったことはあるんですね
だからこのそういうことっていうのは昔からあって
だから好きな人々とは仙人
グルだから いわゆる指導者だから
みんなに祝福してあげるんだから
日本でもこの最近あった麻原ケースとかね
自分が何でもやる 最終解脱しただからもう隅にもう染めないんだと
で 弟子たちには禁止するという生き方でね
そういう気持ちで修行に入る
では最終解脱になって
それから思い存分遊んでやるぞという気持ちだから
冗談じゃないんだ そんなこと
それでお釈迦様はそういう人々を隠遁してチェックしたところで
やっぱりこの人は欲がありすぎ
欲のために これ異常です
異常な欲があったと だから頭が狂ったんであったと
私には異常な欲はまるっきりないんだと
それからこの怒りで ビャーパンなちって
まあ哲学的なものを考えそうなんですけど
どう考えても批判的で怒り的なんですね
このものすごく怒っているわけじゃないんです
この修行しているんだからね
でもこんなのは何の意味もない
これもダメ 誰もダメ なんでこんな世界は？とかね
そういう言葉の中で怒り
怒りで見て だから怒りが宗教になっている場合もありますよ
まあ軽々と世間は否定するわ
人の行動は否定するわとか何とかとか
やっぱり言葉上手じゃないんだから
私もなんとなく激しく言うんですけど
本当は例えば携帯電話の話したって
やっぱりそれ可愛らしく面白く言わなくちゃいけないんですよ
この子たちが 本当にもう何やってるんですか？ってバカなことばっかしやって困ったもんだよとかね
だからそういう風に言うためには
やっぱりすごい言葉の能力が必要ですけど
私にはちょっとできない
漫才の訓練を受けてないんです
しかし まあそれは置いておいて
やっぱりこの怒りそのものを宗教にしている場合
当然あります  どうったことない
キリスト教 イスラム教はもうかなり怒り使ってますから
宗教の衝動として激しく使ってます
激しく戦う だからなぜ悪魔を設定したんですかと
その時点でもう怒りですからね
恐ろしい悪魔がいる 戦わなくちゃいけないと
神にも処理できない悪魔はよくやろうとするんだからね
まあ笑い話ですけど まあとにかくそれはやっぱり笑い話にならないんですよ
人間はやっぱり怒りを衝動にして活動しているんだからね
そういうことで やっぱりある宗教団体が怒りを衝動にして
やっぱり修行していて
やっぱり修行はダメになって怖くなったんだと
次にティーナミっていつでも祈り
ちょっと時間があっちゃうとよく寝る
寝ちゃう だからそうすると
この心っていうのは明晰に回転しないんですよ
そこで真っ暗で虎がいるわ
象はいるわ ライオンがいるわ
毒蛇はあっちこっちいるわ
ものすごいゴーゴーと川が流れてるわとかね
まるっきりない 見えないわ
ものすごい寒いし で ろくに座るところも何もない
もうもうきついところでしょうな
そこで居眠りしていて
パッて目が覚めたらどうなるんですかね
すごく暖かく 気持ちよく居眠りして
だから夢の中でなんか自分が自分の家で毛布もかけて鍵もかけて寝ているようなつもりでしょ
目が覚めてみて とたん真っ暗闇で動物の声は聞く
どこにいるんですかね
狂っちゃいますよ 家 部屋で寝ていたっても
夢で怖くなって起きるもんだから
人間っていうのは 起きても自分の部屋だとわかっているのにも
自分一人だったらなんとなく怖くなるでしょ
なんか怖い夢を見て目が覚めたら
アパートで自分一人で住んでいて
なんとなく怖くなるということだから
この人だったらもう怖くなって終わらないんです
もう狂ってしまいますよ
だからこの居眠り性格
それからウッダタ アウーパサンタチッタ
それからいつでもなんか心がなんか浮つき状態で
もうどちらにもはっきりしない
あれやこれやとかね これでは森の中には生活できない
あちらのこちらの心がいく
あちらの心が飛んでいっちゃうとかね
それからカンキーリチキチ
疑いがある いつでも疑いがある
あれ なんだろう わからんんだろうな
これ何でしょうかね やっぱりわからないでしょとかね
それは何でしょうかね
わからないでしょとかね
もしかするとそうでしょうね
もしかするとそうでしょうのとかでしょうねとかね
そういう性格 疑いの性格というんですよ
それは個人的な一人は知ってます
もしかするとそうでしょう
もしかすると でももう 10 分くらい喋りさせるともう 100 ぐらい言うんですよ
もしかすると と だからこちらがもう一つ言えよと
原因は一つしかないんだからという気持ちです
年上だから黙ってたんです
もう早くもこの人とはもうあんまり仲良くしないことにしますよと
もう決めちゃうんです
もうきついと ちょっと何かあったら
もしかするとこういうことではないかなと
だからデータがあるんだったら一発でわかるんだから
まあまあそうかもしれませんねと
それで終わるでしょう
また もしかするとこうかもしれませんね
もしかするとこうかもしれません
もしかすると どこまでもしかすると言うんですかね
もう性格は良くないんですよ
例えばお腹を壊しましたと
もしかすると この朝食べたものが壊したのかもしれませんね
そうかもねということで終わっちゃう
いや 朝食べたものはそんな大したことない
もしかすると昨日食べたものではないかと
まだちょっと もしかすると昨日ちょっと遅くなって
水曜日 木曜日 水曜日悪いかもしれませんね
もしかするとまた別なことを言うね
もしかすると最近美味しいものを食べてないんだから
もしかするとお粥飲んだらこれ治るかもしれません
もしかするとこれ西洋の薬飲んだ方がいいと思います
もしかしてやっぱりこれは西洋じゃなく
そういう風にもうもう本当にこれ実例で
もうもう 15 分待ってみたんですよ
来るわ来るわ来るわ来るわ
で 私はもうこのアホ それはもう 2時間ぐらい待てば治りますから
で 私は出て行ったんです
それ言わないんですよ
思うことはね もうとんでもないこと思っちゃいますからね
まあ死んだら掃除やるぞと
まあ死ぬぐらいことをたったお腹が壊れただけで
もしかすると もしかすると
だから一緒にいた私の同級生みたいな仲間なんですけど
みんなもう生きてるか死んでるかわからないぐらい
もう明かりがないんですよ
性格の問題で だからしっかりしなきゃあかんということなんですよ
だからこれ いつでもこの疑いがあるということは
仏教専門用語的な言い方でわからないんだけど
本当はこの性格なんですよ
もしかするとあれ もしかするとこれ
もしかするとあれとかね
なんだ こんな性格って
はっきりとデータがあるんだったらある
なかったらないと わかりません
とわかります いや わかります
それで終わるでしょうに
なんか日本のマスコミで韓国の状況を説明するような感じで
あれではないか これではないか
これではないかとかね
もしかするとどちらでもないかもしれませんしね
で 次に 8番目はアットカンサパラワンビ
なんか自分のことを褒めて褒めて褒めて
他人のことを貶したい気持ちがあるんですよ
これは大体はありますよ
なんか自分のことをよく見せて
他人のことなんだ あれぐらいのことというね
その気持ちになるとかなりストレス溜まるんですよ
自分の方が立派で仕事してるんではないかと
なんだ あれぐらいと そういうことって気持ち悪い人に仕事を任せてみてください
もうできないんですよ
あの気持ちで だって人のことを侮辱できるぐらいの仕事しなくちゃいかんから
自分が そんな仕事できるわけないでしょうに
それで他人よりは自分が偉いと
他人はこういう風に貶してやるぞと
あの行者がまあ 1週間しか森の中に修行してないんだけど
私はやっぱり ８日間やってみるぞとかね
日本からもある人 そうやって日にち計算して修行に行ったことがあるんです
私はまあ道相といって
心の中でものすごく笑っちゃったんです
誰か誰かさんが 2週間修行して
誰か誰かさんが 3ヶ月とか修行して
誰かさんが半年間いた
それで半年や じゃあ私は７ヶ月とかに行って帰ってくるぞとか
だから行ったあの一言で
もう私から言えばもうやめなさいと
あんたその時点でもう終わりやと
何もできんとことでいいじゃないでしょうに
この世の中で これが自分のことを褒め称えて他人のことを貶してやるぞという気持ちですよ
全く進めない 進めないとないとどんどんストレスかかっちゃって
体が壊れて病気になるんですよ
ヴィパッサナーのせいにしちゃっても困ります
それでお釈迦様はいろんな宗教家たちがそんな気持ちで言って頭が狂って帰るんだと
次に あのチャンビービールかジャティか
ちょっとしたことで震える
ちょっとしたことで怖いという性格があるんですよ
あ 怖いと だから性格的に
まあこれは皆様よく経験があるという
よくよくあることで ちょっと虫だけ見ただけでキャーと立ち上がって泣くんだからね
虫１匹見ただけでキャーと泣いたり
こうもう体はどけたり
いろんなことしたり 修行もできると思いますかね
その性格で だからそういう風に
ちょっとしたことで怖くなる
もう何といいますか この恐怖映画とかね
もうあのポスターを見ただけでも嫌になるとか
映画見られませんよ それだったら
まあ一応人間で そういう性格の人間います
その性格自体はどうったことはないんですけど
そういうような性格が持ちながら出家して修行に励むと真理発見してやるぞと思ったら狂って帰るしか方法ないんですよ
それでお釈迦様 私はそんな臆病者ではありませんと
だって訓練を受けてるんだから
戦争に行く訓練も 本物の王子だから
そんな臆病者ではありませんと
で 次何でしたっけ？それからラブサッカラシロカンニカーマナ
あの他人から いろいろもらうために
いろんなね お金 こっちは宗教の世界だからね
お布施やら他人から褒めてもらうために
他人からこのもういろいろ褒められるとは
もう尊敬されるわ それでお布施もいろいろ入って
結構立場がいいという
あの気分の良さ狙ってるんですよ
というか あれは気分いいんじゃないんですよ
みんな誤解してるんですよ
そんないろいろお布施したりしたりする人はいいんだけど
もらったりすると 私はそんなに気分がいいとは思えない
もし気分がいいならば
その人にはお布施を受ける資格はないんですよ
お釈迦さんはっきり言ってますよ
あーよかった お布施もらってとか
これくらいと だったらもうそれは借金になるんだと
あんたは輪廻で返すことになるんだよと
本当はすっごいお釈迦様にしたっても
すごくそれ気分が悪いんですよ
まあそれでも出家の外から見て
あ いいな あの人 あの人
いろんなものはお布施してもらっちゃうし
拝んでもらっちゃうし
みんな褒めるわし いろいろあることでは
よかったよかった 私もやっぱり出家してやるぞと言っちゃうと
それで修行に入っちゃうと頭狂って帰ってしまう
お釈迦様にしてみれば
ひとかけらも何かもらいたいっていうことはないんですよ
誰にも褒めてほしいとかね
ないんですよ 別に褒めてくれなくたって大きな御世話やと
だってインドの一番一番上のカーストの王子で
もうどうせ頭いいんだから
もう隣の国取りたければ簡単に取れるし
いくらでもできた人だから
何ら関係もないんだと
だから私は大丈夫やと
それからくしたひのびら
怠け者で頑張らない 怠け者で頑張らないと森の中に入ってみたら終わりですからね
だから我々の日常生活の中では
怠け者で頑張らないとストレス溜まるんですよ
いろんな仕事をしなくちゃいけないんだから
例えばご飯食べたんだけど
皿洗わない 怠けて それで次のご飯食べたら
その皿もそちらに残っちゃいますね
これ自体すごいストレスですよ
ということで 怠け者にもストレス溜まると
次にムッタサティ サティ
12番目 ムッタサティアサンパジャナ
集中力がないというか
サティがないというか
もう何が起きてるかわからない
いつでもボーっとしている状態
このサティっての反対はボーっとしている状態ですよ
いつでもボーっとしている
何が起こるかわかってない
で  4番 14番目は智慧がない
頭が悪い でお釈迦様がやっぱり自分のはその一つもないんだと
その特色は そこでこう考えたから
あ 自分だったら大丈夫や
どんな恐怖感にも立ち向かえる
この修行はできると だってこのこの研究してみたら
このいろんな修行者をね
いろいろ欠点を見つけたんだと
見事に自分の心にそれはないんだと
では自分が合格だと それでストレス消えちゃったんですよ
あ 合格だと できるんだと
そういうことで ストレス消すためにこの 14の項目を勉強するしかないんです
それからお釈迦様はそれで森の中にずっと六年ですからね
6日間の修行合宿明照会ではなかったんです
絨毯の上で暖房をつけて
で 森の中で生活のこともその件説明していますよ
やっぱり突然ものすごい音が聞こえてくると
いろんなもの 突然物が落ちたりとかね
その時は頭が狂うことはないんですよ
なぜならあれ  14もないんだから
あ これが神が怒られたとかね
神に怒られるとないんだからね
もしかすると私の心バレたかもしれませんとかね
ちょっとしたことで怯えることはそういう意味です
時々この孔雀がどこかの木に止まるとかね
孔雀だいたい夜活動するかな
どうかわからないんだけど
かなり大きい鳥だからね
木を登ったりすると このあの皮が乾いている木なんかよく登るんですよ
それで皮が落ちるんですね
落ちたらこの大きい鳥がパタパタパタともうそこでまた登ると
そこら辺に虫を食べたり
蛇を食べたりする あるいはそこら辺の何か鹿やら何か獣なんか飛んでいくとかね
時々枯れた枝がドーンと落ちたりとかね
時々ずっと真っ暗闇の中で風が吹いてくるんだと
葉っぱの木の間で その時はすごい音がするんだけど
そんなもんかと このみんな気が狂って帰ったのはと
やっぱりこれ性格が悪いんだからストレス溜まって気が狂って帰っただけで
いや 自分がどんどん喜びを感じる
ああ 大丈夫やで 大丈夫じゃないかなと
それで それでも恐怖感が出てくると
だったらまだ悟ってないでしょうに
びっくりしますよ ずっと瞑想していると
突然ボーンと何か自分のそばに何か落ちてきたら
例えばもう木の上で猿が寝ていて
猿がもうもう夢見て居眠り状態でもう転がっちゃうと
もう落ちちゃうと どうしますかね？これ怖くなるでしょう
びっくりするでしょうに
そんなのはしょっちゅうあったんだと
いきなりなんだこれっていう感じで
楽ではなかったんですよ
修行は しかし 立派な方っていうのはこういうことをしたんですよ
座っている時は もしそんなことでびっくりして
心臓がビクビクビクビクする状態になったら
座ったまんまでそれ消すんだと
あ これが猿が木から落ちただけやと
まあそいつはもうそのまま寝ているでしょう
朝までとかね そんな感じで
この座ったまんまで そのビクビク状態は消すまでいる
立っている時は怖くなったらそのまんまで
そのビクビク状態 恐怖感を消してから次に歩いていくと
私はそういうことを決めたんだと
だから 例えば歩いている時で
いきなり何かびっくりしたってしまったら
そのままで その状態はずっと消して
落ち着いてから次の一歩をであると
すごい性格しっかりしてますよ
決まりはしっかり守ると
あのぐにゃぐにゃ状態は何もない
やっぱりダメだ やめようということは全然ない
で これが覚えておいてください
それがすごく大事なことですよ
皆様方はと言ったっても
人間っていうのはストレスはストレスは心配は悩み事はあるんだと言ったっても
あれは引きずる現象ですよ
引きずる現象 お釈迦様は引きずる現象っていうのは見事に消してるんですよ
特に女性の方々は まあ子供が何かトラブっちゃうと
これ 24時間引きずる
買い物に行っても持っていく
何かどこかで他の用事があって出ていて
それ引きずって持っていくんで
この問題は 解決はしません
引きずるんだから 問題を起こしたのは昨日かもしれませんし
しかし この親子の関係の問題は
今日もある 明日もある
明後日もある 何年も続く
これがこの引きずる現象で
例えば 1週間前で万引きして見つかったと
自分の子供が そこで困ったりして緊張したり悩んだりするというのは当たり前ですからね
そこはその場で解決するのは普通ですよ
言ったら自分が言って
なんだ なんだ こんなこと
なんでそんなことするんですかと
怒鳴るなりに蹴るなりに殴るなりに
なんかその場でパッとやって
あるいは子供に学校でもう家に帰るなよ
お前二度ととか何とか言って
家に帰る それでけろっと忘れておかないと引きずって持ってくるんですよ
それで子供がもう家に帰るなと言ったのに
家に帰らなくちゃあかんだから
もう家に帰ったって もうわかってますよ
もう母親が問題を持ってるんだっていうこと
そこでなんだあんなことでまた始まると
次の日も始まる 次の日も始まる
それであの問題はどんどん悪化して
もう解決できない状態になる
子供は家出するか 学校を辞めるか
不良に走るか 人殺しになるか
そうなるまでお母さんっていうのは絶対めげない
とにかく引きする だからそこはもう会社の人々にあるんですよ
会社でちょっと侮辱されたんだからって
家までなんで引きするんですかね
これは会社のドア出た途端
別な世界だから だから座ってる時は上司に何か言われて嫌な気持ちになったら座ったままで消せと
それを 方法は何でもいいんです
どうせバカバカにバカに雇われてるんだからいいんじゃないか
それで一生尽くもんだからとか
なんとかいい加減なことを思っちゃうと
もう治りますよ 私言うことは決して怒られるようなものじゃないんですよ
私は面白い半分で言うんですよ
バカに雇われた運命だから
しょうがない もう退職するまで
そう思っただけで面白くなっちゃう
だから面白さが出てくると
あの嫌な気持ちが消えてしまいますよ
それだったらほとんど問題は解決する
だから私は 私 この経典に言ったら
この引きする現象 お釈迦様は見事に解決してあったんです
問題を受けたらその場でそこで解決して
もう終わったと次に行くんです
だから悩むっていうことはとんでもないことで
過去のことで そこである日
お釈迦様のことをある人が神ですけどね
あんた方 ろくに食べるものもない
住むところもないし でもなんかえらい贅沢しているように
こんなおでやかで体輝いて顔色が美しくて
で 今日は私の顔色悪太郎
女性の方がいて ちょっとかわいそうなことになりましたけど
それはまあ瞬間の出来事で
そうかと まあ で 顔色が綺麗で
これは何なのかと そしたらお釈迦様がおっしゃったのはアティータン
うーんと アティータン
アーミソーキャント 過去のことについては悩まない
ナッパジャパンって あなた方が将来のことについてもいろいろごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ悶々と考えてないんだと
パッチュパンネーナヤーペンで今の仕事で忙しいんだよと
そんな暇がないんだと
今の現在のやることは忙しいんだと
過去に悩むこと 将来について悶々と考える
そんな暇がない だから我々はすごく充実感があって
明るくて元気でいるんだと
人々はそんなことをやって
竹のように 色が消えてしまいますよと
で 大体そんなもんで もう一つぐらい経典を紹介して終了します
この緊張することをリラックスできないということ
昔もあったんですよ 今もある
これからもある これは人間にはもうどうしてもついてくる
だからリラックスということを誰も人間はわかってないんだから
ついてくるのは当たり前
リラックスということは
ベストコンディションでいることなんですよ
ですから それをわかってないんですね
で ある人が人と言っても
このある神様 神ですけどね
心霊ですけど お釈迦様にこういうことを言うんです
ニッチャンウットラストミダンチッタン
心はいつでも怯えているんだと
震えているんだと ニッチャンウッビガンイダン
同じ言葉でいつでも浮いてるんだと
怖くて怖くて安定していないんだと
どういうことかというと
アヌッパンネースキッチェス
これからどうなるでしょうか？これからどうなるでしょうか
これからどうなるでしょうかと
いわゆるこれから来るであろうというものについて
心がいつでも怯えて震えて不安定でいるんだよと
それだけじゃない あとウッパティテースチェ自分に起きた出来事について
これがどうしよう これがどうしようということで
また苦しんでいるんだと
ですから 心には安らぎがないということでお釈迦様に聞くんですよ
サチェアッティアヌットラスタンタンメアッカーヒプッチと
もし怯えない リラックスした心
安定した心ってそんなのはあるんだったら
この世の中に だって人間にはこれから起こることってのはどうせあるでしょうし
今やらなくちゃ起きてることどうせあるでしょうし
だから怯えないことっていうのはあるならば教えてちょうだいと
っていうことは やっぱりみんな困っているということなんです
お釈迦様ちゃんと答えますが
もうやっぱり皆様実践できないんです
で 何やったらボッジャータパサ
やっぱりこの七覚支を育てることで
で 頑張ること そうすると心がきちんと成長します
それから なんにやったらサッブニッサーッカ
すべてのものから離れることやと
捨てることやと それで心が安定するんだと
だからできないでしょうね
だったらまあ緊張一方で生活しなくちゃいけない
いや こんな大したことないんですよ
できますよ まあ七覚支っていうのは別に勉強しなきゃダメですけど
それよく見るとちゃんとしっかりした心育てる方法ですよ
すごい簡単にできます
このものを捨てるっていうことは
みんなあの もう本当に理解してないんですよ
捨てろという必要ないんですよ
あなたのもの何もないんだから
この誤解なんです あれは私
これが私の これが私の
もう本当に恐ろしくアホなんですよ
この体さえも自分のものじゃない
勝手でしょうに で
は自分の体痛くなるのは好きですか？髪の毛が白くなるのは好きですか？いくら年取っても真っ黒い髪で頭いっぱいやった方が好きじゃないの？歯がもう二十歳よりも
二八とか三十代ぐらいの歯であった方がいいんじゃないの？腰が痛いとかね
膝が痛いとか それ楽しい？楽しくなかったらやめてください
そんなのは できますかね
禿げちゃったらかっこいいと思いますかね
かっこ悪いというならば禿げないことですよ
でもできますかね 何一つもできんでしょうに
だから私は禿げたくないという気持ちはあるんだけど
髪の毛は勝手に禿げてしまう
頭が 私は腰も肩も痛くなってほしくない
凝ってほしくないんだけど
これ勝手に凝ってしまう
がんにはなりたくないんだけど
これ体勝手にがんになったりする
だからもう捨てると言ったっても
それ自体も成り立たないんですよ
持ってるんだったら捨てると言ったってもいいんだけどね
この愚かな生き方 この愚かな気持ちというかね
この無知が問題ですよ
体が私のものやと思った瞬間から
体が可愛くて守らなくちゃいけない
助けてあげなくちゃいけない
まあこれでもこんな仕事しちゃうと体が壊れるそうよとか
だから仕事しないことになったりとかね
今は眠い 人っていうのは寝なくちゃあかんだからとかね
もうゴミですよ 結局はっきり言いますから
もうもう生ゴミです そういう生き方っていうのは
だからお釈迦様は捨てなさいよと
というのは 持っていた大事なもうもうルイ・ヴィトンのカバンを捨てなさいと言ったようなことじゃないんですよ
何も持っていなかったんだから
もともとも体さえも 結局心さえも自分の希望通りに改善しないんですね
だから何のこともないんですよ
すごいちょっと理解するだけでもうすべて捨てたことになりますよ
それが心の究極的な安定なんです
これからはもうストレスはない
でお釈迦様があの修行で悟ってから
堂々と自慢しますよ あのシンハラーで獅子声という経典で
まあ私はもう森の中でライオンが吠えるような感じで吠えますよ
それぐらい自信がある
誰が来ても どんな質問しても答えてあげますと
わしは言うことはそうでないと言える人っていうのはいませんよと
人どころか神々にも誰にもできんやと
すごいチャレンジ的に喋る
だから乗り越えたんだからなんです
そういうことは大体人間には誰にでもできることで
で 頑張ってほしいと それから皆様の役に立つことを一行言いますけど
いろんな仕事が出てくると
楽に仕事をこなすためにやる方法っていうのは
この過去と将来を忘れることなんですよ
忘れて秒単位で仕事をする
命は秒だと 仕事は秒に限ると
秒って短いんだったら分にしてください
命は分やと 生きているのは分やと
仕事も分に限るとと言って
その分は頑張る しっかりする
たった分だから大丈夫ですよ
たった分だから悩むことバカバカらしいでしょうに
たった分の仕事できないと思う人がいますか？だから人生は分やと思ったらできない仕事っていうのはなんかバカバカらしくなるんですよ
分じゃなくてこれ年に伸ばして考えるんだから
この仕事はできませんと
私は自分の個人的な例と言ってはいけないんだけど
言ってしまったんですけど
歴史の話 どう考えたっても
小学校の時からももう歴史アレルギーの人に
教授たちの前で発表できる研究レポート書けると思いますかね
あまりにももう無責任というか
でも見事に書いてうまくいったんだから
私の場合は だから私はレポートとか考えなかったんですね
ああいう風に その瞬間
その瞬間 何か読んで あ
これが面白いなと だから初めて読むもんだからね
あ こんなこともあったっけと
次のこと あ こんなこともあって
それはちゃんと頭の中整理して
ずっと書いただけでも
やって結果が だから結果見たっても
私は驚くも何もなかったんです
別に すごく熱いレポートが
俺が書いたんで こんなんなん別にどうってことないと
まあ分単位の仕事だから
だからやれば何でもできますよ
分だけ仕事するんだったら
だから分仕事をしないでください
分で十分です 分だけ生きてみれば
何一つもストレスはたまりません
それで つまらない仕事ややりたくない仕事やら任されちゃうと
嫌で嫌でやってはいけません
断るか 断るのはみっともないと思うならば
嫌な仕事でもやりたくない仕事でも
人の役に立つと だから頼まれたと
だから それはもう大変大事な仕事だと
わがままを言うんじゃなくて
嫌なことでは思わないんだと
大事なことだと思ってやることですね
それで終わりと思います
どうもありがとうございます
[効果音]